can you do a Big R for me
Ah that's amazing good boy David is just
five unlike most children his age he's
super excited about Christmas
why are you hoping that Father Christmas
will bring you
um
what color but this is David just two
weeks ago inside an intensive care unit
he has sickle cell disease and was in
agonizing pain
what did your mommy bring into hospital
because she was worried about you so my
phone was blown David had flu and the
infection was making his condition much
worse
David would never tell you if he's in
pain how would just assume that is in
pain but once David said my bone is
cracking I know definitely something is
not right with him he was immediately
transferred to a specialist unit here at
St Mary's Hospital in central London
where he received a blood transfusion to
help him to fight the virus it was
terrifying I can't even hold back I was
trying the nurse had really trying their
best like distract me but it's just like
me looking my own son lying there
helpless it's just
it's just too much really for any any
mom to go through yeah
David's case was complex for Dr Whitaker
and her team but in her Wards and across
the country there has been a spike in
respiratory viruses and flu among young
children
we have lots and lots of children coming
in they're all quite sick there's a
shortage of beds that we are always
worried about flu we're trying to keep
everyone moving through the system so
that every child can get the care they
need and we've set up Community
treatment to make sure that we have
access to get the patients out of the
hospital
and this rise in cases is putting
pressure on wider surfaces that are
already struggling to cope
the NHS insists it has been planning
ahead for this Pediatric Intensive Care
pressure
we have around 10 times as many patients
with flu in hospital this week as we had
in the same time last year but if you've
been planning for so long why have we
got to a stage where there's an acute
wattage of Pediatric Intensive Care Unit
beds it's not unique to this country
other countries have also been seeing
these infections coming back in the
United States RSV has been a particular
problem okay should we say thank you
David should be going home soon to wait
for a racing car from Santa at his
hospital bed won't be empty for long oh
she's Josh he's Sky News at St Mary's
Hospital in London